olivier 57 ans est en arrêt maladie
depuis 18 mois suite à la pandémie de
kovy de 19
il n'a pas pu se faire poser une
prothèse de hanche le 25 mars dernier
après une fracture du col du fémur après
six mois d'attentes pour avoir une date
d'opération il va devoir prendre son mal
en patience
olivier le comprend et prend la nouvelle
avec philosophie
j'étais en attente de mise pour une
prothèse totale de hanche
voilà donc une prothèse de hanche dont
l'opération était prévue le 25 mars 2020
donc qui gère six mois d'attentes
malheureusement avec le colis de 19 aces
qu'il arrivait bien entendu les hôpitaux
de souffle bien entendu des gens comme
ça pourtant que comme moi comme ma
situation et c'est bien normal
et pour combler l'ennui en attendant une
prochaine opération
olivier a développé de nouvelles
passions comme la photographie depuis sa
fenêtre étant donné que je suis aussi
confiné chez moi pour raisons de santé
également et bien une autre passion que
j'ai c'est aussi de prendre un peu des
photos de la fenêtre de voir un peu ce
qui se passe à gauche à droite sur lyon
et donc voilà je prends pas de photo de
de ma fenêtre de la part du des terreaux
des alpes de la croix-rousse enfin de
tout ce qui se présente un quotidien
difficile pour olivier qui doit faire
face à une mobilité réduite entre
supérettes de proximité livraison à
domicile et vente par correspondance
il a donc dû trouver quelques astuces
pour s'approvisionner